le témoignage qui relance la piste
munsterman c'est celui d'une collègue
caissière de sylvie aubert elle a
reconnu suspect munsterman aurait
partagé parfois la pause déjeuner de la
jeune femme disparue le 14 novembre 1986
à l'âge de 23 ans employée d'un
supermarché de chalon sur saône sylvie
aubert faisait chaque jour le
déplacement entre la firme de ses
parents à saint loup de varennes et son
lieu de travail
son corps très abîmés n'avait été
retrouvé qu'en 1987 dans la rivière
donne les enquêteurs disposent également
d'autres témoignages attestant de la
présence dans la région de
chalon-sur-saône du véhicule d'ulrich
muenstermann un camping-car blanc et
bleu les gendarmes savent aussi que le
tueur en série allemand fréquenté à la
même époque une salle de sports de
chalon ville où il a séjourné quelques
mois en 1986 et c'est un interrogatoire
serré efficace que devrait être soumis
ulrich muenstermann car trente ans après
les faits les enquêtes reste fragile
faute de preuves adn fiable sans compter
que les scellés ont souvent mal supporté
l'épreuve du temps
si cette piste est aujourd'hui réouverte
c'est sur l'impulsion du parquet
d'auxerre qui a décidé il ya déjà huit
ans de se pencher sur tous les dossiers
criminels non résolues depuis plus de 20
ans et justement le nom du tueur en
série allemand revient dans nombre
d'affaires non élucidées
ulrich muenstermann a été condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité en
septembre 2012 dans une autre affaire le
meurtre et le viol de sylvie bâton en
1989 à avallon dans l'yonne